the Nobel Peace Prize for 2015 is to be
awarded to the Tunisian National
Dialogue quartet it established an
alternative peaceful political process
at a time when the country was on the
brink of civil war it was thus
instrumental in enabling Tunisia in the
space of a few years to establish a
constitutional system of government
guaranteeing fundamental rights for the
entire population
voila cosmic bill to encircle vana
cartoon senator Baraka for fossil equity
reversal versa
New Jersey inshallah came upon jetty
water be sure that inna the far that in
a manner with over the Hobart he were
added let them understand American
economy
you